ce matin sur ces news la polémiste
ellizabeth levvi est revenue sur la
marche contre l'antisémitisme qui a eu
lieu hier à Paris lors du débat elle a
eu des propos qui ont suscité de vives
réaction ellisabeth au sujet de
l'antisémitisme montant en France
regardez c'est le débat du jour
êtes-vous choqué par les propos
d'Élisabeth Lévi oui ou non les Chéries
on les revoit et vous nous donnez votre
avis chez vous et ici c'est parti
regardez c'était ce matin regardez ce
qui est terrible si vous voulez c'est
que maintenant l'antisémitisme soit
devenu pour un certain nombre de gens
dans les quartiers un marqueur euh que
d'une hostilité contre eux aujourd'hui
l'antisémitisme qui pose un problème de
vie aux Juifs il vient en général de
musulmans pas des musulmans deux
musulmans bonjour Merci Elisabeth lev
d'être avec nous il est 20h2 on est en
direct Elisabeth Levi sur C news ce
matin et on a Nasser également qui est
avec nous Nasser qui est un ami he voilà
un ami qui vient nous voir souvent mon
Naser et qui me voilà qui aime bien
donner son avis dans l'émission on a
aussi besoin d'avoir des gens voilà de
la de la vie normale comme on dit font
pas télé qui son vient de nous donner
leur avis merci Nasser en tout cas
d'être là euh est-ce que vous êtes
choqué par les propos d'éisabeth Levi on
va revenir là-dessus avec elle bien
entendu qui est choqué pour Gill Verdez
bien sûr c'est de l'islamophobie elle en
fait son fond de commerce c'est énervant
je la respecte en tant que personne mais
pas en tant que chroniqueuse c'est
ralbol de ça en fait vous jouez sur ça
vient de musulman et pas des musulmans
comme ça vous pouvez pas être attaqué
vous savez très bien c'est une arguie
juridique mais c'est honteux de dire ça
c'est honteux de dire que
l'antisémitisme est lié au musulman
c'est dégueulasse c'est faux et c'est
honteux donc j'en ai marre je suis pas
choqué je suis dégoûté dégoûté
ellisabeth qu'est-ce que vou je suis
absolument fascinée d'abord à venir
répondre ici écoutez franchement d'une
vérité qui est absolument maintenant
évidente pour tout le monde alors je
vais donner quelques éléments à Gilles
Verdez pour lui rappeler depuis 2000
depuis 2015 je remonte pas avant mais je
pourrais tous les juifs qui ont été tués
en France parce qu'ils étaient juifs l'
était au nom de l'Islam par des
musulmans deuxièmement les territoires
perdus de la République je vous ai
écouté g Verdez je vous ai écouté
m'insulter et maintenant vous allez
m'écouter je ne vais pas vous insulter
mais je vais quand même développer mon
argumentation deuxièmement les
territoires perdus livre paru en 2002
avec des témoignages de professeurs
confirmés par le rapport obain d'un
inspecteur général de l'Éducation
nationale un ans plus tard démontre que
dans les classes si vous voulez des
quartiers relativement islamisé des
quartiers comme la saint s où les
musulmans les institutions musulmanes
elles-mêmes disent que l'Islam et la
religion
majoritaire dans ces quartiers on ne
peut pas enseigner l'histoire de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale des Juifs ont à
peu près il en reste quelques-uns
quitter l'école publique enenseine sint
où j'ai moi-même habité donc je ne vous
parle pas en l'air et pour terminer cher
Gill Verdez c'est pas le jour parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis allé voir la
projection
organisé par l'ambassade israélienne des
films réalisés à partir des massacres du
ramas et que voit-on d'accord alors bien
sûr ça ne se passe pas en France mais je
viens de vous donner des éléments pour
la France c'est un phénomène absolument
planétaire que voit-on on voit des gens
qui massacrent des et je je ne vais pas
faire de gorge je ne vais pas vous
donner de détail mais il faut plus que
massacrer qui massacr et qui torture des
femmes des bébés des hommes on voit des
corps brûlés décapité au nom il crie je
veux dire on a dû entendre 100 fois ces
gens crier à la Akbar alors il faut
vraiment être dans un dénis absolument
sidérant d'accord pour croire que
aujourd'hui si vous voulez
l'antisémitisme qui casse la gueule à
des gamins juif l'antisémitisme qui se
drape honteusement des fois dans la
cause palestinienne 2014 j était des
manifestations pour Gaza mort au Juifs
d'accord il y a une dame dont la petite
fille avait été tuée par Mohammed qui
était à Sarcel quand elle a entendu
sécit de mort au Juifs d'accord elle a
quitté la France pour Israël et enfin je
reviens d'Israël et je peux vous dire
que tous les juifs français qui ont
quitté la France à mais pas à guêé de
cœur qui ont quitté la France à
contrecœur je veux dire je n'en connais
pas un qui est quitté à cause de
l'extrême droite même si il y a
certainement à l'extrême droite des gens
qui dans le dans leur cœur sont
antisémites euh et ces gens-là sont tous
partis à cause de la montée d'un islam
radical et de ce qui et de ceux qui
l'accompagn si vous voulez alors j'ai
beaucoup de mal à comprendre en réalité
j'ai vraiment du mal à comprendre et je
vous cite un dernier exemple
sonondagifope
d'accord 15 % des musulmans
reconnaissent éprouvver de l'antipathie
pour les Juifs soit une proportion
supérieure de 10 points à celle mesuré
dans l'ensemble de la population
française alors un autre jour je vous
aurais peut-être répondu très gentiment
en essayant mais là si vous voulez ça
suffit j'en ai marre de cette dénégation
de ce déni car vous n'arriverez jamais à
régler un problème dont vous niz
l'existance et qui est à vrai dire cher
Gill verd je suis désolé de vous le dire
absolument évident je veux dire ça se
voit l'œil nu par tous les prof Kevine
Bossuet a publié dans causeur un long
témoignage il enseigne en scène
Saint-Denis de ce qu'il entend juif est
une insulte madame l mais moi je vous
connais pas mais moi je vous ai vu la
télévision je vous ai jamais vu prenez
de l'amour du matin j'allume je prends
un café je vais chez sur C que j'aime
bien Pascal pro je vous vois ccher sur
l'islam le soir je rentre après une
balade de vélo on arrive à à 21h15 je
remets islam et qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive m les on vous a filé un mauvais
couscousse à manger quand vous étaes
petite c'est le petit caner qui vous av
volé votre trousse qu'est-ce qu'on vous
a fait madame
les moi je trouve tout drôle Mo oui
trouve ça
drôle vomir
par mélangez tout toute la journée en
train de craser sur mes parents sur
leurs parents sur des millions de
musulmans du matin au soir c'est marrant
vous vous connaissez pas il y a pas une
fois je vous ai entendu parler d'amour
ou de bonnes choses ou de vivre ensemble
ou d'êuse-moi je parle d'amour je parle
d'amour en privé pas mir oui bon bonjour
madame LVI effectivement c'est un
Français de confession musulmane qui
vous parle effectivement moi je je je
sais pas ce que vous faites dans la vie
réellement j'ai vu ce que ce que vous
avez dit effectivement c'est à vomir et
si tu me permets C s'il te s'il te plaît
j'aimerais faire une lettre d'excusees
justement à Madame Lévy moi en tant que
Français de confession musulmane et si
tu me laisses une minute j'irai au plus
rapide madame Lévi nous musulmans on
s'excuse c'est vrai on s'excuse d'avoir
sauvé la France lors de la deuxième
guerre mondiale conquise en 3 jours
seulement par le nazisme lors du
bitkake nous sommes allés au front avec
des prières qui visiblement ne
dérangeaient personne à cette époque-là
pendant que la majorité des Français
collaborent bien à l'abri et qu'une
infine minorité de héros résistait
difficilement tant la délation s'vissait
nous musulmans madame LVI on s'excuse on
s'excuse parce que l'imam de la mosquée
de
Paris Abdelkader mes qui a sauvé des
Juifs de la xénophobie du gouvernement
il abritait est déclaré à l'autorité
comme musulman pour les protéger
regardez-moi s'il vous plaît non écoutez
je vais vous regarder il a risqué sa vie
pour celle d'autrui pour des autres qui
pensaient différemment de lui il a été à
la guestapo ça c'est un nom qui doit
vous parler sûement torturé puis
déportter à Dao vous connaissez ça aussi
je suppose en juillet 1944 nous
musulmans madame lesv on s'excuse car
nous sommes allés jusqu'à les accueillir
et les protéger dans notre pays
d'origine ouais et nous sommes opposés à
leur
déportation nous musulmans madame les
viis on s'excuse on s'excuse d'avoir
reconstruit la France des Trang
glorieuses lorsque le pays a été ravagé
par la misère et la famine et pour finir
madame Lévy vous qui êtes esséiste il y
a quelqu'un qui s'appelle Albert Camu
que j'aime beaucoup vous savez qu'il est
en Algérie et il a pratiquement l'un des
mêmes métiers que vous parce que vous
êtes éiste aussi et il dit la la bêtise
insiste toujours alors il faut laisser
parler voilà bon et ben je vais
peut-être répondre c'est extraordinaire
donc je vous parle de fait tout à fait
concret je vous parle des territoires
perdus de la République je vous dis que
des enfants juifs ont quitté l'école
publique et vous m'expliquez que ce sont
les musulmans qui ont sauvé la France
alors je le répète je pense que ça ne
concerne pas tous les musulmans par
ailleurs il y a malgré tout dans
l'histoire des Juifs dans le monde arabe
un certain nombre de pogromes qui ont
précédé donc ça n'est même pas la
question israélienne ils ont précédé la
naissance d'Israël à partir et à partir
du moment où les Juifs n'ont plus été
dimis alors là c'est devenu une haine
antijuive qui est repris aujourd'hui
dans l'ensemble du monde arabe et que me
dites-vous qu'il y a des gens
heureusement je le sais il y a
d'excellents français parmi les
musulmans je vous dis jusqu aujourd'hui
si aujourd'hui si vous êtes sincère je
vous crois sincère alors moi je vous le
dis sincèrement vous devriez vous
inquiéter avec moi au lieu de m'insulter
vous devrez z dire ce qui se passe dans
nos bonlieux aujourd'hu pour les Juifs
est inacceptable est-ce qu'il est
acceptable pour vous que la synagogue de
trappe est brûlé est-ce qu'il est
acceptable que des Juifs quittent
l'école publique parce qu'ils sont juifs
et que juifs pour un certain nombre de
de petit de jeunes Français musulmans
c'est une insulte est-ce que vous pouvez
au lieu de me parler
d'amourig est possible au lieu de me
parler d'amour de répondre à cel
mameondez pas Madame g Gill tu voudrais
répondre on a tu vas répondre dans un
instant Gill Paris qu'on va se retrouver
dans un instant avec elizabe Levi il y a
Jordane Bardella aussi qui viendra nous
voir dans un instant on va revenir sur
la marche contre l'antisémitisme hier
dans toute la France avec Jordan
Bardella on viendra il sera face à lactu
Jordan Bardella puisquon viendra sur
toute l'actualité voilà avec lui
notamment Guillaume meis qui était hier
à l'antenne de retour et puis on viendra
sur cette question Jean-Marie Le Pen
était-il antisémite c'est la question on
a envie d'avoir la la réponse de Jordan
mardella et bien sûr sur les propos du
député LFI David guireot sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon reviendra bien sûr sur tout ça
dans un instant à tout de suite on est
en direct à tout de
[Applaudissements]
suite